all right how's it going bros my spam
pad you guys tired of this game yet of
course you're not everyone [ __ ] loves
this game I kind of like it last one we
beat 95 we're gonna try night six now I
assume it's just ridiculously hard like
I don't even want to answer that the
place is closed down you can't stop me
from working we have one more game over
tomorrow
Asia where you're gonna form stay close
to the end make sure they don't hurt
anyone
okay around all problem with taking my
trip myself okay
okay so I don't know I feel like they
can make it harder the night five right
how much harder can they make it no
one's in the vent we got this for us I
know you believe in me and I want to
make you proud baby girl
Baby Cakes so far it's pretty identical
to night five I don't see the difference
yet I'm sure I'm gonna have to eat up
those words pretty soon if I know this
game by now logic funny uplink Ellis's I
mean I just come on I was just one more
and then we're done with this game
alright just want to move on with my
life you know there's so much [ __ ] going
on like I don't even [ __ ] know how to
[ __ ] anymore oh [ __ ] I think I was too
close and slow I wasn't ready for that I
made it pretty far though I'm pretty
sure I can do it what the [ __ ] that's so
creepy
oh my god so fine what what was that
hahaha come on so what am I supposed to
do there ah come on if anyone's scary
if anyone's scared at the game at this
point they're bullshitting come on I
don't want your [ __ ] cupcake you
[ __ ] [ __ ] I like your panties though
they make me wet
that's so [ __ ] hard Oh how's she said
never now are you kidding how am I
supposed to do it then how am I supposed
to do with it you can't double [ __ ] me
double [ __ ] me all right you're
watching it very the pride man right now
bris oh so that's a moment of sincerity
that I'd try to came out naughty varlet
yeah bloody mullet there's no time for
anything anything what am I supposed to
do I love Nickelback
I love Nickelback a lot of Nickelback I
love Nickelback what
there's no time there's no time oh my
god what I checked come on come on come
on come on come on come on no one loves
me cuz I'm ugly no one loves me cuz I'm
ugly I have a strategy now that I'm
fairly certain we can do it rest we can
do it breath say it after me I can lick
my anus say after me bros we come on we
can do it because we will lick their
anus it's not gonna work if you don't
say it wow so selfish always been so
selfish
alright my tactic is charge it to max
double flip double click click click
double click on charge it to max uh-huh
double click
double-click uh-oh
sir maker suck my dick you [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] licking mother [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
suck my ass for a UH like oh you're so
fun to think that we could have been
done by now roses that thought is a very
depressing card oh Jesus
I don't know if I was fast enough that
means I wasn't exactly if there's a
single tiny bit of [ __ ] you get
[ __ ] titty [ __ ] I flashed oh just
take my face and [ __ ] mouth it off
and eat it up with your [ __ ] it what
what am I supposed to do against golden
freddy we got this bros it's only three
amber we got this for I am suck my ass
oh
ah we got this as long as a gold ass
[ __ ] oh you thought you could [ __ ] me
but I said no oh my god this is some
[ __ ] ass licking oh god oh god oh god
suck my ass Empire of a sectional or
teens yeah blah blah
Oh buttons cover smoke up our our
discovers remarkable become solid
shintaro me like a block chicken helmet
- a blob al-arab and vedenskaya not a
fluid Asif Lou what are your size I had
it
I now have Ebola nice try see sister
suit sister meal guarantees oh not a
sweet [ __ ] sensation of milking oh
[ __ ] you
go [ __ ] yourself tonight on best game
ever
that was so [ __ ] hard I never want to
play this game again I never I'm so done
oh my god okay quick quick review when I
started this playthrough I was very
sarcastic and very like oh this game
sucks everyone just thinks it's popular
but then I kind of got into it more and
it has a cool backstory it has really
cool characters and has jump scares and
it works and most of all it's
challenging as [ __ ] and if you enjoy a
good challenge this is a game for you
I enjoyed the challenges but I it really
[ __ ] pushed me to the limit man so
you know what I'm really glad to play
the game and I'm really glad you brought
share this with me I think it was a
really cool thing I'm just so [ __ ]
happy right now I'm just gonna go and go
and [ __ ] lay down because I have a
headache as [ __ ] from all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] bros I love you
thank you for watching this stay awesome
mm-hmm